[Music]
so what do you do for a living neil
paige
marketing marketing super super fabulous
isn't that nice uh look i don't want to
be rude but uh i'm not much of a
conversationalist and i'd really like to
finish this article
friend of mine wrote it so don't let me
stand in your way please don't let me
stand in your way
the last thing i want to be remembered
as is an annoying blabbermouth
you know nothing grinds my gears worse
than some chowderhead who doesn't want
to keep a big trap shut
if you catch me running off of the mouth
just getting a poke in the chops
oh that feels good oh god i'm telling
you
my dogs are barking today
oh
that feels better
i have a terrible feeling know what
that we didn't do something wow now you
feel that way because we left in such a
hurry
we took care of everything believe me we
did did i turn off the coffee
no i did did you lock
up yeah
did you close the garage
that's it i forgot to close the garage
that's it
no that's not it
what else can we be forgetting
kevin
[Music]
so
[Music]
that was a long time ago at least a year
before her team came to live with us for
good wow
and became my real brother beautiful
you must have sat up with that all night
baby
[Music]
my parents still think i make ugly up
they say if he's so real then where is
he
but just like i told daddy just because
you can't see the
air doesn't stop you from breathing
and just cause you can't see dog it
don't stop you from believing
then daddy smiled and said son
that's what we call faith
before we begin since this is aunt
bethany's 80th christmas
i think she should lead us in the saying
of grace
what dear
grace grace
she passed away 30 years ago
they want you to say grace
the blessing
hmm
[Music]
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation with
liberty
amen amen amen you have taken the land
which is rightfully ours
years from now my people will be forced
to live in mobile homes
on reservations your people will wear
cardigans
and drink high balls we will sell our
bracelets by the roadsides
you will play golf and enjoy hot hors
d'oeuvres
my people will have pain and degradation
your people will have stick shifts the
gods of my tribe have spoken
they have said do not trust the pilgrims
especially
sarah miller gary she's changing the
words
and for all these reasons i've decided
to scalp you
and burn your village to the ground
[Music]
he's not a team player he's a special
child but he needs friends
do you need friends like this
you said your grandmother was sick and
you had to take care of her and i love
that about jesus
so proud of you where is she i would
love to meet your grandma
i'd love to meet grandma cheryl no baby
you don't want to meet grandma cheryl
you know what okay grandma
baby aunt may gonna ask you not to go
get grandma don't disturb grandma
i think it's the perfect time for it i'm
asked that you let grandma rest
because every time grandma come out
something different starts to happen we
don't have to impress nobody with
grandma
walter your old ass need to do something
now you sitting there like you don't
hear the [ __ ]
lonnie you don't want her to get grandma
yeah mr hobbs it's me on the intercom
all right yeah i think someone sent you
a christmas gram
dad
all right uh let's get it over with
i walked all day and night to find you
um you look like you came from the north
pole
exactly where i came from santa must
have called you
oh yeah sure he uh just got off the cell
phone with me
you did so go on go on with what
well are you gonna sing a song or
something or can i just go back to work
a song uh
yeah anything for you dad um
uh i'm i'm here
with my dad and we never met
and he wants me to sing him a song
and um i was adopted but you didn't know
i was born
so i'm here now i found you
daddy and guess what i love you
i love you i love you
if you're coming from the street with
dirty shoes on your feet
that's a technical foul
if you switch the radio to somebody
music
show that's a technical foul
if you don't shut the door
after using the refrigerator
[Music]
[Music]
oh this is such [ __ ]
in this house
[Music]
you guys know this can't possibly work
of course it'll work let's get that
green let's find my phone
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
use your shoes
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
this goddamn bird i'm trying to get an
angle so would you spot well this moment
[Laughter]
sit down baking soda bacon
you goddamn faster
[Music]
[Music]
you